[Musique]
il y va de la vie
si tous quand est astucieux bellemène
le plus sérieux à jouer vite devenir
amis qui suit arrive tout encore au
touquet encore aux skieurs ou mais
qu'est ce qui s'passe cuit déjà les
doutes et les est bercée par la mélodie
et ut endormi je suis épuisée fabrice et
qu'est ce qui s'est passé c'est tous ces
voyages ah ben c'est tous ces voyages
toutes ces semaines toutes les semaines
sur rien du tt en chine aujourd'hui on
repart encore pour 1 pour elle ou un
tapis je n'en peux plus tu veux déjà
joué maintenant mais oui je ne dit même
pas bonjour amis voir de si beaux jours
en plus pardon de mme et rendormi quel
épaves ou lol lol ah bon alors je
commence par dévoiler la carte du pays
que vous avez à découvrir
voici la carte géographique de ce pays
et vous arrêtez vous au paddy dont ça
m'a tout l'air d'être une il s'assied
grand rue 6 3
c'est grand et la capitale est là alors
je sais que c'est joli virevolter dans
cette île handi dont 1
nous allons regarder le drapeau ah oui
voilà un drapeau qui rappelle en quelque
sorte le drapeau britannique ans un
simple dans cette portion la wii et puis
alors 10 12 et usé les belles nuits à
huy où ça me regarde toutes ces étoiles
ma vie je vous signale que le drapeau et
bleu assez foncée la bourbince sur les
couleurs du drapeau anglais
rouge blanc et bleu et les étoiles elles
sont blanches ballon enfin dans ce pays
on dit bonjour oui on parle anglais ça
ça ne devrait pas vous étonner - ou
demande marie brizard symbolique
souligne jacques rami
mec alors vous avez une petite idée de
ce qu'est cet immense pays qui est en
fait une île mais une île aussi grande
qu'un continent
vous voyez voyez pas c'est l'australie
voilà l'australie est la capitale de
l'australie ici va être canberra qui est
une qui n'est pas la plus grande ville
du pays mais qui en est la capitale
fédérale et la voile à canberra ça
s'appelle canberra et ben alors
maintenant fabrice tu peux aller in the
garden toulouse a gardé in the garden
goût d'ailleurs de la garden tout veut
gordon to the garden à la srwt a gelé
tous ce point commun se retrouver tous
mes petits camarades
c'est incroyable j'ai tout en me
contredire vous avez vu non à la tht
bonjour les jumelles âgées surtout quand
il ya bien longtemps que vous avez vu
bientôt qu'un bon alors vous êtes prête
pour le point commun mais oui bon alors
j'appelle rien gagné fabrice oui venez à
laval a bola
j'arrive j'arrive aux jeunes et rosières
qui est là fabrice tiozzo a pris au bon
jour mais chérie ça va ça va ça va soc
bah alors dit moi la famille c'est le
point commun
bon tu connais je n'ai entendu le point
commun vous interpréter chacun
personnages ont un objet nous essayons
de savoir le point commun existant entre
vous voilà c'est bien ça et je commence
s'il te plaît alors tu es quoi
aujourd'hui
alors moi je suis absolument
indispensable pour les amateurs de
musique
enfin je parle de musique enregistrée
parce que si vous voulez entendre les
tout derniers enregistrements réalisés
selon les procédés les plus modernes et
pas si vous avez une somptueuse
installations avec des haut-parleurs je
crois qu on appelle ça des des baffles
c'est vrai moi je dis bravo
oui alors dans tous les points d'appui à
ça il faut avoir ça si vous parlez de
wifi de stéréo ou si vous ne possédez
qu'une modeste gabonaise de pick up qui
ne comporte même pas de changeurs de
disques et bien dans tous les cas vous
avez besoin de moi et vous avez avantage
d'ailleurs à manier avec beaucoup
beaucoup de précautions voilà bah si tu
allais alors non nous sommes plus
ensemble fabrice on peut bien dire qu'on
ne voit jamais
l'un sans l'autre oui mais moi je
travaille plus que toi oh mais c'est pas
vrai si t'es pas là tu serais bien
occupée ont remarqué qu'aucun froid on
n'a pas de taux de tous en vue de
travail
cui et dans ces cas là on les croise
et puis il ya des moments où on vous
sert paper passe quand vous amenez vos
mii firme pourrait presque bouzid oui
oui oui m'enfin là vous m'aidez un petit
peu mais je crois que je suis quand même
sans la voix j'attends la version 2
pouces moussu pour être sûr de moi robin
moi moi alors je ne suis pas méchant du
tout du tout et vous ne risquez rien à
vous servir de moi ah je suis votre
repos oui je suis un siège un bon gros
sièges bien confortable dans lequel vous
pouvez vous laisser aller
tenez par exemple pour regarder la
télévision enfin pour pour dire la
vérité je ne suis pas le siège tout
entier non j'en suis qu'une partie oui
celle qui est bien utile pour lire ou
pour fumer la pipe
voilà là je parle pour votre grand père
et puis tout simplement pour se reposer
car c'est grâce à moi on est bien mieux
dans un fauteuil que sur une scène
ça y est voilà ça y est tu as trouvé oui
je vais un petit peu peur au départ là
parce que tu me parlais du fauteuil fin
tu m'as dit après je suis une partie du
fauteuil et oui et oui je pense que ce
détail vous aura permis vous aussi de
découvrir de quoi il s'agissait en fait
si je ne me suis pas trompé tout cancan
devrait être un bras de pick up ce qu'on
appelle le bras c'est à dire l engin que
l'on met sur le disque 6 1 voilà c'est
ça ensuite vous étiez tout simplement l
eau aux idées des bras des bras normaux
des voix dont on se sert le bradera le
bras gauche il est drôlement fin avril
ah oui alors ce qui concerne tous bosser
c'était le bras du fauteuil dans le jus
qui permet de le sac ou d'être repos en
quelque sorte
il y faut oui mais je ne suis pas le
seul à je suis sûr que tous nos amis
avaient découvert également la même
chose j'en suis certain ben jawad
fabien maxime être aussi fort dans les
jeux suivants je vais essayer
nous allons dans quelques instants
participer au jeu musical bien entendu
alors que poussent ou celui du
certainement réviser son orthographe
bowie au wild dieu sait s'il en a besoin
aulas oui alors tu veux que j'aille
écrire évidemment oui parce que cette
semaine c'est un mot difficile alors là
j'ai peur un mot très long où ça
s'arrête embêtant certes tu vas au
tableau oui tu as été un mot très long
un mot très long we bord tu n'as pas
oublié mais non mais je les enfermer
dans ma poche j'ai du mal à sortir voilà
alors c'est un petit incident t annonce
alors tu l'a très bien
alors écoute c'est un mot en dilek
trulli dans l'eau potable eaux va être
assez grand on va essayer la première
alors la première c1 h
h oui et alors lui petite reine comme
d'habitude 4 5 6 7 et enfin le 8 et la
dernière la leur la dernière c1 e 1 e
voilà alors tu m'as bien 10 h la
première lettre et eux la dernière
voilà un écho à la la la la la la la la
c'est alors qu'est ce que ça peut bien
être que ça je dirais c'est une plante
oh non non non ce n'est pas une plante
une fleur de peau une fleur un animal
c'est un animal pu finir un animal prend
alors un gros howitt assez bon quand
même
il est assez gros iranien ah oui il
court très vite justement je te le
disais il est habité court très vite et
riil et il était un animal d'afrique non
au nom d'europe
non non non non non non d'asie n'en
trouve pas partout on en transport dans
les pôles encore nous on en voit dans
les eaux mais ici en europe un poisson
non non
non non c'est pas un poète ta mammifères
qui va dans le rhône on non plus non
mais là tu te nature brûle pas du tout
là un mollusque
non non je suis carrément perdu 1 2
pattes ça deux pattes un court très vite
je te conseille pas de prendre un tout
petit c'est bête parce que d'un coup de
patte de cette bête c'est comme un
cheval ça fait très mal au bas du dos et
est sûre tu en as une écoute toi tu veux
une aide supplémentaire
oui alors je vais donner la quatrième la
sécurité at et ce à deux pattes ça de
pas ça court vite sapori tu m'as demandé
tout à l'heure si j'en avais ou en
afrique
oui bah oui on en afrique à boganda ah
oui mais ça viendra toujours vivant
c'était en afrique n'y avait que
distraire maintenant tu dois avouer mais
alors là là là nous sommes en pleine
folie alors pouces moussu
parce que si c'est l'animal auquel je
pense et agit de ce serait une autruche
et ben voilà avant j'en étais sûr ah bah
voilà une autruche et c'est facile de
travailler avec lui comme l'autruche
avec un show départ oui alors nous
allons écrire autruches débat harry avec
un r us et h&e à redon et tu mets un
acheteur marque oui il en faut pour tous
quand c'est voilà mon pauvre pouces
génie mais on n'a même pas d'achat
autruches tu comprends ça n'existe pas
ah bon pourquoi tu ne dis rien tu
laisses faire je comprends tu trouves ça
normal et ne devait pas savoir non plus
mais moi je me suis trompé je me suis
trompé et qu'outreau de jeudi je dois
pas être très intelligent mais situé au
no 2 et je sais que l'autruche r elle
n'est pas non plus très intelligente ah
bon il paraît que pour l'attraper il ya
des chasseurs qui se déguise en autruche
et avec des plumes
il marche comme elle et elle se laisse
prendre on attendra bien ça se fera bien
essayé mais un jour de d'attraper une
autruche de cette façon-là f
tu me vois déguisé en autriche aurait dû
alpes ou smooth chute aurait du mal du
pointu regular oui tu ressembles pas une
autruche comme ça au premier abord
abete contre moi je ressemblerais plus à
une autre qui arrivait on pourrait
peut-être aller voir notre ami wind band
le jeu musical
bah oui on doit nous attendait dans
l'événement on nivard et tabriz excuse
moi je n'ai vraiment pas pu venir à
notre rendez-vous du lieu commun c'est
pourquoi je me suis permis d'étayer les
petites amies saisie oui c'est pas grave
et ceci personnes fans mais c'est très
amusant on commence notre petit jugan
jeu musical à huy duc manh a tenté oui
les notes à la place de thé hésitation
c'est hexavalent je commence mon
histoire c'est un monsieur très élégant
soigner raffiné bien habillé un monsieur
qui est sûrement des cobayes des corps
et décors des coûts qui mérite autant
ouais je mets le riant oui c'est
monsieur a décidé de partir en voyage
c'est son droit et il a envie de se
bander ce vacants se barder c'est son
droit de se balader
cette balade la wii et ses voyages il
veut le faire en bateau tu sais comme
cela ce passe autant de la marine à
voile
je souhaite à ce monsieur de trouver des
vents favorables aux défenses un vent
favorable de cette façon sa traversée
sera ici
aussi je le mets en bas le ray est
attendue le mien c'est plus joli comme
ça oui je trouve ça assez bon alors
qu'est ce que je voulais dire encore
très bonne histoire voilà il veut
continuer son voyage et si vous pourrez
même faire le tour du monde s'il en
avait envie oui eh bien moi je lui
conseille d'éviter les grandes villes il
n'a pas l'habitude de ces villes qui
sont de véritables labyrinthes et un
labyrinthe
elle a directement été ferais remarquer
que c'est parce que je suis très
gentille je lui niall ce danger ça me
paraît facile 6 jan
c'est l'enjeu ya s'il voit que quelque
chose ne lui plaît pas c'est pas si il
lui suffira de tourner le groupe de
tournée le crew le chien au rebond alors
le dos tourné le dos et c'est ça voilà
et il n'aura qu'à revenir à son point de
départ
ce n'est peut-être pas aussi facile que
ça pas si ce n'est peut-être pas aussi
passible se voit pas ah ah ah que cela
paraît très très difficile
oui je crois alors tu relis les notes de
musique idées reçues la voie qu'il ya
une petite chanson alors et l'as far et
la si do ré mi
mais l'entité coquette petite
oui oui oui on voyage monsieur du mot
laissé seul
[Musique]
c'est vrai mais c'est vrai c'est ça oui
voilà renoncé mais fait pousser un petit
peu ah ben je répète un peu avant
maintenant c'est excellent conseil pour
toi tu viens chanter avec pas jarry
jette à temps
les dates ni sait déjà par konami de
toute la vie qui se plaignent que la vie
majed désiste et rzeszow fait des choses
les comme juni pas de mine war niveau à
faire attention les quatre amis sont
descendus ti meilhac
ça me saoule de retard isère amis
il
j'arrive à jouer entre lui et ses amis
[Musique]
vouloir devenir amis
oui
[Musique]